الاحصائيه كما ذكرت تجاوزت الخمسين شخصا
سابدا في الحصيله الاكبر في ملاطيا حيث
الحصيله ما زالت كما اعلنها والي مناطق
قبل قليل ثلاثه وعشرين شخصا
لقوم في شهر اوروبا 15 شخصا لقوا مقطوعهم
و30 شخصا مصابا في شهر اوروبا بينما عدد
المصابين في ملاطيه كان حوالي 420 في
العثمانيه 65 مبنى دمر وايضا خمسه اشخاص
لقوا مصرعهم ايضا في شارلي اورفا كنا او
في اضنه ايضا هناك حديث عن انهيار عدد من
المباني الحديث عن ثلاثه مباني وتصدى في
مبنى اخر ايضا كنا نتحدث عن شامي اورفا
التي بلغ عدد الضحايا فيها خمسه عشر شخصا
في العثمانيه كان والتحدث عن خمسه اشخاص
كل الجهود الان المستنفره حتى الوصول الى
المتضرره عشر ولايات تقريبا تضررت نتيجه
الزلزال كل هذه الولايات الولايات
الجنوبيه اجهزه الدوله بالكامل في حاله
استنفار حتى القوات المسلحه التركيه وضعت
طائراتها على عهده الاستعداد لنقل الطواقم
الطبيه وفرق الانقاذ الى مباشره الى
المناطق الجنوبيه الهلال الاحمر التركي
يعلن ايضا عن
نقاط للتبرع في الدم في حال استدعت او
طلبه المشافي في الولايات الجنوبيه اي
مساعدات عاجله بالعموم نتحدث عن دمار في
عدد لا يقل عن اربع او خمسه ولايات شهدت
تضررا كبيرا حتى الان المنطقه التي ضربها
الزلزال والتي المتوقع ان يكون فيها حجم
الدمار الاكبر هي ولايه كهرمان مرعش وايضا
ولايه غازي عنتاب التي ضربها زلزال اخر
بقوه 6.6
بعد اجهزه الاول بحوالي 15 دقيقه هاتان
الولاياتان لم تصدر عنهما ايه تصريحات
رسميه عن اعداد الضحايا